you
culture just exists whether you want it
or not if you don't manage it properly
you might create negative and
counterproductive cultures that don't
really emphasize the things that are
going to serve your organization
culture was readily dismissed up until
the late 1970s as something that
managers don't need to care about but as
organizations and work becomes more
complex and people no longer work on an
assembly line when you can basically
procedurally tell them what to do and it
doesn't really matter what they think
because the assembly line solves all the
dilemmas for them as as robots are
replacing these and people are put more
and more in positions where they need to
make decisions there's no way we can
exhaustively kind of describe all the
situations that employees are going to
to deal with and that's where culture
comes into play it's when there are
these implicit understandings about what
is important and what isn't important
and what we're trying to maximize and
what we're not trying to maximize and
who we are and who we aren't and there's
also this kind of moral code that holds
us together then you would expect that
on average employees would do the right
thing even if you haven't specified
precisely the recipe of how to do it so
that's why culture is becoming
increasingly more important than
organizations and is increasingly
recognized by leaders as something that
they need to invest in
we basically find that people follow one
of three trajectories either they show a
gradual increase in their level of
cultural fit so basically they're slowly
learning the code and behaving
appropriately these are people who stay
in the organization and succeed we see
people who never really show an increase
in their level of cultural fit relative
to what they were immediately after
joining the organization so that
indicates to us that they're either
incapable or unwilling to adapt
culturally and those are the people at
extreme risk of being fired so basically
these people if they survive a year and
they rarely do they have a 50% chance of
being fired by that time and finally we
find I think the most interesting group
of people are those who demonstrate this
inverted u-shape these people who are
capable of adapting but at some stage
start showing a decline in their level
of cultural fit and that's a strong
indicator of these people's intention to
leave voluntarily so really we see these
different signatures in terms of
people's and culture agent trajectories
and how those relate to their outcomes
in in the organization
so imagine like a group of software
engineers that all sit together in the
same room and pay play ping pong and
after hours and know one another those
type of groups can really tolerate the
non conformist weirdo and that might
actually be a very good thing for the
organization because that weirdo so to
speak right this person who's not
behaving in the appropriate way is
probably also a reflection of the fact
that that person is bringing new ideas
and new sensitivities and has different
ways of thinking of problems and that
might be really important for the
organization's success especially if
this organization needs some innovation
and and a new thoughts in order to to be
successful with its product offerings so
you know we find that there's this
trade-off between your ability or
tendency to behave in a compliant way
but also the security relaxed data or
thereof that you gain from the extent to
which you're part of a titanate group or
not and really being in in the right
kind of sweet spot leads to the greatest
success in organizations
on average having a strong culture is a
good thing if everybody if everybody is
aligned on the same important values and
if we would expect therefore that faced
with the same kind of situational
dilemmas everybody would solve them in
roughly the same way and in a way that's
conducive to the organization's strategy
then yes a strong culture is going to be
beneficial for the organization but at
the same time you don't want echo
chambers especially if you're an
organization that competes on novelty if
you're a Google or an aspiring Google or
if you're in Amazon or if you're even
innovating in retail and if you're
innovating in transportation you don't
want your organization to be an echo
chamber you want to empower your
employees to also take risks sometimes
and think outside of the box
some organizations are architected in a
way where actually people aren't part of
strong groups the kind of crisscross
different functional roles and teams in
a matrix kind of structure so in those
organizations people would probably put
a strong emphasis on being culturally
compliant and there will be strong
rewards to strong cultures that
everybody is aligned around however you
can imagine other types of organizations
that are built of strongly connected
groups where inside the group people
have very strong familiarity within it
with one another and very intimate with
one another in those groups you can
afford or those individuals can't afford
to behave in a culturally non-compliant
way and it might be the case that those
groups if they have a good mix of people
who are compliant and non-compliant are
the ones who might come up with the most
brilliant and innovative ideas so it's
not that there's a kind of
one-size-fit-all recipe that facilitates
how culture kind of translates into into
good operational results from an
organizational point of view different
organizations different organizational
architectures and different strategic
imperatives prescribe different and
intricate relationships between
structure and culture in the
organization